before we get on to the topic for today
i felt like last
monday's lecture was not my best i don't
know why it's not that i didn't put time
on it i looked and i had the
wrong
lecture numbers on slides it was all
kind of chaos i'm sorry about that
sometimes you put in a lot of effort and
you still give a lecture that isn't all
that clear so let me try to tell you
what i thought were the main points
i started off by saying why it's really
fundamentally important to be able to
understand not just what people look
like for from the outside but what we
really care about people is what's going
on on the inside about their thoughts
and their beliefs and we are constantly
making inferences about what people
know and believe and want and think
uh and we do that all the time to
understand why they're doing something
and to predict what they'll do next and
so it's fundamentally important it's
kind of the essence of being a human
being in many ways it's the essence of
literature
and
and we do it all the time
and a classic way that people have
studied false beliefs is
thinking about other people's thoughts
is with the false belief task the sally
ann task that i described and the reason
people use the false belief task rather
than just a belief task is if the
beliefs are true you can answer what
somebody will do based on the world not
based on their mind and so to unconfound
the two we use a false belief that's
different than the state of the world so
we can be sure we're asking people uh
what will happen next based on what that
person believes
and
uh through decades of use of the um the
sally anne false belief task and
variations of it
it's clear that there's a very
distinctive developmental time course uh
an ability to solve this problem
five-year-olds solve it no problem
three-year-olds systematically fail
and people with autism
typically get
past this task late or not at all
high functioning people with autism uh
pass the task just later like seven
eight nine years not five years old okay
so that's the kind of behavioral
background evidence that there's you
know something distinctive about
thinking about other people's minds
then we considered whether they're
special brain mechanisms uh and i argued
that yes there are there's a bunch of
them but the most impressively selective
one is the tbj shown up there
and evidence that it's specifically
involved in thinking about other
people's thoughts comes from the fact
that that activation is a greater
activation when you think about when you
solve the false belief type problems
when you think about another person's
thoughts compared to when you think
about a representation of physical
representation like a photograph or a
map okay so those are sort of logically
isomorphic
problems where you have to
always answer a question about a
representation it's just a
representation is in somebody's head or
it's a physical representation in the
world and in that difference you get
that region of the brain
okay so that's cool because it's a very
kind of um
nicely nicely designed kind of it's not
quite nothing's a minimal pair but it's
a minimal pair in some respects right it
carves out uh whether the representation
is mental or physical
um
but it doesn't solve everything and a
suite of other tasks have shown that
that region is actually specific in a
whole bunch of other respects
it doesn't respond just whenever you
think about a person their external
properties
and most impressively it does not even
respond when you think about their
visceral body sensations like thirst and
hunger and pain
so the tpga doesn't respond to just any
thinking about any any mental states of
another person it's specifically
thinking about their thoughts and
beliefs and that's pretty damn
remarkable right it's how abstract can
you get and yet here's a specific brain
region for that very abstract very
specific thing
um and the final little bit of evidence
i showed you is that it also generalizes
it's not just about language because you
can show people um movies that have no
words in them
but that clearly show characters who
must be thinking about each other's
thoughts and in those moments when the
characters are thinking about each
other's thoughts that region turns on
more for example than uh when they're
thinking about each other's pain okay
yeah and did somebody look into
what happens if other people think about
me or if i think there's me thinking
about me
if other people you mean if you're
thinking about other people thinking
about you or yeah exciting um yeah i
would assume that that region would be
engaged i'm sure there's studies on that
because because you're thinking about
their thoughts right but more
is it more interesting probably just
because it's more salient
right i mean i actually oddly in this
class i talk about attention at the end
which is weird because attention is a
an issue with every study but most of
the brain regions we've talked about
surely including this one are modulable
by how strongly you're attending to
something
so if something's really salient or
important or
you know uh you're really paying a lot
of attention to it you're gonna get more
activation and if it's more interesting
to think about what other people think
about me
than to think about what other people
think about each other
you'll you'll find some modulation in
here i'm sure
okay
and then finally i talked about moral
reasoning as a test case it's not that
the tpj is selectively involved in moral
reasoning it's that many of the critical
aspects of moral reasoning depend on
what a person knew at the time
and so to use that information in moral
reasoning you need to pull that region
in so i realized i wrote that question
ambiguously on the quiz i meant to ask
is the tpj engaged specifically or only
in moral reasoning to which the answer
the correct answer would be no
but i didn't put the only in there and i
decided it was ambiguous so if you said
yes you got the points
anyway i gave several bits of evidence
that um
using the moral reasoning case
that the tbj is
is
[Music]
stronger evidence that's involved in
thinking about other people's thoughts
first that we showed that in people with
autism who have this difficulty in
thinking about each other's thoughts
even once they can pass the false belief
task they put less emphasis less weight
on what the person knew at the time when
evaluating the moral status of their
actions
okay it's not that they make a mistake
or that they're unable to morally reason
it's a pretty subtle thing is just a
small difference in how much they weigh
what another person knew at the time
okay
so that was that's also known as less
forgiveness or less exoneration for
accidental harm
right you kick somebody by accident and
they go ouch
well maybe you get a little bit of blame
because you were a klutz and you should
have thought or something but it was an
accident so you should be exonerated
people with autism exonerate slightly
less right
um
okay so we then talked about the the
fact that if you zap the tbj with tms
stick a coil there right you do the same
thing you slightly reduce the weight
people put on what the person knew at
the time in their moral evaluation of
the person's
actions
um and then i showed this bizarre fact
that as i think gisela asked
shouldn't the tbj be different in people
with autism yes absolutely according to
all of this it should be but the basic
univariate measures how big it is how
selective it is where it is do not find
a difference in that region with that
contrast in high functioning people with
autism that's surprising
but one possible answer to that is even
though it's there and it's just as big
and strong and all of that
it's um
that doesn't mean it doesn't represent
different information and i showed you
an example that in
typical people you can decode from the
tpj whether the person is reading about
another person's intentional harm or
accidental harm
and you can't in people with asd
okay so that's my
summary of last time uh and then all of
that was focusing very particularly on
the kind of most fancy quintessentially
human aspect of social cognition which
is this business of representing each
other's thoughts and beliefs
but i pointed out at the end that all
right that there are also lots and lots
of other facets of social perception and
social cognition many of which have
somewhat selective brain regions lots of
them other parts of the brain and we
just didn't have time to for full
treatment
okay
hopefully that was a little bit clearer
than i was last time
okay so so far in this course we've been
focusing on all these bits of brain that
seem to do very distinctive often very
selective things okay so the one we've
just been talking about is that little
guy right there
but we've talked about a lot of these
things in here
and
the field of human cognitive
neuroscience has invested lots of effort
to find these things and try to
characterize what each of them does
and that's pretty cool right this is all
stuff we didn't know 20 years ago and
it's nice and it's like counts as real
progress i think
um but it
leaves lots of things woefully
unanswered
these none of these regions can act
alone even though i've depicted them
somewhat
in a somewhat silly fashion as nice
little you know m m's on the brain
none of them act alone none of them
could act alone they need information to
process so there has to be input to each
region they need to be able to tell
other regions what they figured out or
there's no point
and probably as they solve a problem as
they conduct their computations they're
probably interacting all the time with
lots of other regions
so we desperately need to understand not
just that you know this patch does faces
there's lots more we need to know one of
the things we really need to know is
what is it connected to and who is it
interacting with
okay
okay
so that's what i just said and so that
means looking at not just the cortex
that we've been focusing on through this
whole course this dark matter that's on
the surface of the brain up there
uh but today we're gonna do a kind of
figure ground flip on the brain and
we're going to start paying attention to
all that stuff that used to be
background down there
all that white matter underneath which
is like a big heap of myelinated fibers
that connect long-range regions of the
brain to each other okay
so you might say okay just wires who
cares about the wires that was my
attitude for a long time i've gotten
over it
we desperately need to know about the
wires for all kinds of reasons so i'm
going to go through a whole bunch of
reasons and there's a lot of little
details and i don't want you to panic i
just want to give you the gist of
why this is worth paying attention to
okay
so first of all
white matter makes up 45 of the human
brain
so that alone tells you it's not like
some trivial thing as a big part of your
brain
this is all the more interesting
because that's not true in other animals
so um i think white matter makes up a
higher percent of the human brain than
any other animal or at least we're way
up there in mice it's only 10 percent
and maybe that's a relatively
uninteresting thing about scaling with
brain's highs but maybe it's something
deeper about human brain what's special
about the human brain and nobody knows
and here's a fun fact if you took all
the myelinated fibers in the human brain
and you laid them out end to end you
could go around the world three times so
we've got lots of cableage sitting in
here
okay
so
i briefly argued before that you simply
cannot understand the cortex without
understanding uh its connections of one
region to another it's just
crazy to study one little patch of the
brain and not know who it's talking to
and where it gets its inputs from
and as i just said that the the um
pressing need for that knowledge is
heightened by the presence of this map
which we didn't used to have now that we
have this map it's all the more
important and pressing to know what the
connections of those regions are
okay
so here's a nice quote making this point
this is heidi johnson berg and matt
rushworth they say
connectivity patterns define functional
networks the inputs to a brain region
determine the information available to
it
whereas its outputs dictate the
influence that brain region have on
other areas
therefore simply by knowing the pattern
of inputs and outputs of a brain region
we can begin to make inferences about
its likely functional specialization so
i think that's a nice quote it makes the
point that
that it's not just that we need to know
the connections but the connections and
the function are bound to be deeply
enmeshed one constrains the other
yeah
okay
further recall way back which will quite
possibly return on the final exam how do
we define a cortical area i gave you
criteria for a cortical area and one of
the criteria was a distinctive pattern
of connectivity right so it's part of
the identifying
properties of a cortical area is is what
it's connected to
and
so that's another reason we should care
a third reason is if we knew of a given
cortical area what its long-range
connections were to lots of other
regions
that connectivity fingerprint remember
we talked briefly about connectivity
fingerprints a month or so ago
that fingerprint this distinctive set of
connections of that region
you can think of it as a signature of
not not just how that region differs
from other regions in that same
individual brain
but
how we might find a homolog of that
region in another species
and that would be a very interesting
thing to do
like wouldn't it be cool to know
is there a tpj
in macaques
well macaques can't solve an analog of
the
theory of mind task
chimps we could debate a little bit in
narrow domains kind of sort of a little
bit not really
macaques no okay
um so
do is there a homolog is there a
corresponding region that maybe
you know
we took that region and we adapted it
and made it work better so we could do
better things with it and if so what is
it doing in macaques right i mean i
think that's just a totally cool
question and in principle
one way to say what counts as the same
region across species which is kind of a
weird question they're different species
so what would the same region mean
one way to say what the same region
means is to have a similar connectivity
fingerprint
okay so there's several studies that try
to do that i couldn't cram them into
this lecture but if you're interested in
reading on it reading about it shoot me
an email i'll send you some papers
okay
i also mentioned that the specific set
of connections of a cortical region
particularly its inputs play an
important role in development remember
the rewired ferrets if you redirect the
input to what would have been primary
auditory cortex in a ferret
and you have it have that input come in
from the eyes
you can get what would have been primary
auditory cortex to become a lot like
primary visual cortex
so connectivity is important not just in
how a region functions and how we say
what counts as the same across species
but is probably also crucially important
in the development of regions
okay i also showed you evidence that the
visual word form area we can pick out
exactly where it's going to land in an
individual brain by the connectivity
fingerprint of that region before kids
learn to read
further evidence that connectivity
determines later function
okay if as if this is not enough other
reasons to care about white matter
is that disruptions of white matter are
at the root of many clinical disorders
dyslexia autism
developmental prosopagnosia amusia all
of these things
and others for all of them
disruptions in long-range
white matter connections have been
implicated as possibly playing
an important role
in the
in the
etiology of that disease
aging most definitely
decline in white matter is prominent in
aging
sorry to say there's a 10 decrease in
white matter fibers per decade starting
at age 20. use yours now while you have
them
let's change the topic
okay
um there's a lot of talk about how white
matter connections may change with
experience and learning and plasticity
and um that's a pretty patchy literature
and um it's not a very impressive
literature the classic thing you
probably learned in 900 that when you
juggle you get changes in white matter
connections from juggling expertise
maybe maybe not there's problems with a
lot of that literature so it's an
interesting question but it's not clear
what the strong answers are
and finally
i don't know about circuit design
probably some of you do but i gather
that people who think a lot about
circuit design one of the key features
you need to take into account is wiring
length you want to keep wiring lengths
short
right you have conduction delays you
have heating you have space taken up in
circuits all of those things
are bad in circuit design and they're
bad in brain design too there's a lot of
reason to think that a major
factor in the design of of brains
especially human brains is minimizing
wiring length because wiring length is
very expensive metabolically you got to
maintain ion gradient gradients across
across cell membranes
it's expensive developmentally these
damn things need to figure out where to
go and if they don't go to the right
place you have a developmental disorder
and um so it's probably a real cons
constraint on designs of brains
okay so that was a whirlwind lots of
reasons to care about white matter and
connectivity
oh plus at least in animal research
there's a whole suite of amazing new
methods for looking at
connectivity in animal brains
and min young could tell us more about
that than i could
because she's working in a lab that's
right at the forefront of developing
those methods someday we're going to
apply those methods to a human brain i
can't wait to get the whole
wiring diagram okay
anyway
so what do we know about the
connectivity of these regions
well you may be thinking don't we
already know all this stuff after all i
showed you this diagram way back and
you've probably seen it in every damn
course you take in this department
it's in most textbooks in the field
the whole wiring diagram of the visual
system so don't we already know all this
stuff so what's the big deal
well here's the big deal
that's i'm a cac brain
and in macaque brain you can get the
actual answer to what is the actual
structural connectivity of this patch of
cortex to that patch of cortex
you do there's a whole bunch of methods
but traditionally you inject some dye
here that's uptaken by neurons that
travels along axons that goes here you
kill the animal slice up the brain and
find that tracer over here and then you
know those two things are absolutely
connected that's the gold standard and
that's the basis of most of those
studies that method and variations
thereof
but we can't do that in human brains
and so we do not have anything like this
information in human brains yes whether
it was a stone
oh that is a compilation this was
published in i think 1991
um but that was a compilation of heaps
of studies that have been done before
that it was a big review article looking
at all of this literature
where lots of classic neuroanatomy
people would do these things where they
would inject tracers and slice up brains
and look in other places and it was just
a vast amount of literature that did
that for many decades it's sort of
fallen out of favor even though these
things are at least
i don't know
these are really crucial questions now
people use other methods to do that you
can use all kinds of optogenetic and
other methods to map connectivity in
animals yeah
in here
oh that's a good question uh i oh it's
probably dorsal and ventral pathways let
me see here
yeah
yeah the red ones
this is another thing i didn't even
really
mention probably let alone give short
drift that was lame but anyway
the visual high levels of the visual
system we focused on the ventral visual
pathway coming down the bottom of the
temporal lobe but there's a whole other
visual pathway that goes up into the
parietal lobe did i talk about that a
little bit reaching and grasping no i
didn't lame
lame lamely anyway
um major part of the field i didn't get
to
anyway it's a whole other part of the
visual system that seems to be more
involved in visually guided action
and
they're very they're actually very
interconnected but they're trying to
emphasize that the dorsal pathway is at
least somewhat separable
in monkeys
but my point is this is monkeys where
they have the gold standard methods and
they can actually discover the real
connectivity
um sadly we can't do those things in
humans
um and in humans we have only three
methods
and none of them are very good so we'll
talk about them today anyway because
this is such an important question
but the bottom line is this drives me
out of my mind we basically don't know
the connectivity of any of those regions
for sure in human brains
and um somebody's got to solve that
maybe one of you will go invent a method
that works in humans that helps us solve
that problem because it's actually
um i think really paralyzing to our
field but so i'll tell you what we do
know which isn't much but you know
beggars can't be choosers okay first
method has been around for a few hundred
years
and that's gross dissection and i mean
gross
i like that kind of gross
so only good for postmortem brains but
it's really quite amazing this is a
bottom view of the brain back in front
um and you can actually this is actually
a physically dissected brain like it
takes a real serious neuroanatomist you
know and lots of fancy methods i mean
not fancy methods but lots of careful
precise teasing apart of bits of brain
and you can actually see
these big fibers coming up here so if
this is the back of the brain and we're
looking up like this what do you think
those fibers are connecting right there
big fiber bundle
coming from deep down in the brain
up to
right in there is that that was the
primary weight report bingo exactly
okay so that's the lgn right there and
this is called the optic radiation it's
this huge cable of fibers that come up
okay first here's the um optic track
actually i forget that's not i think
this is the optic track that's been
snipped there then it comes up in here
makes a stop in the lgn and then this
big batch of fibers comes up right there
to primary official cortex okay
everybody got that
um okay so you can actually see it in
dissecting a dead brain
okay that's pretty cool
um
but what if we don't want to wait for
people to die
often we want to ask questions about a
person right now in their brain do they
have this disorder are they at risk of
that disorder
you know what is what is their
connectivity
so for that we have two methods and i'll
talk about these two methods in the rest
of the lecture the first one is
diffusion imaging
okay so i talked about this briefly
before but let me remind you of what the
basic principles are
so
uh here is a picture of the optic nerve
with a bunch of axons oriented like that
it's a big
cable with a whole bunch of little
fibers in there
and the basic kind of biophysics is that
water wants to fuse more along this
length
following the orientation of the fibers
then it wants to diffuse this way
okay and diffusion imaging i'm not
explaining any of the physics but just
take it for my word that what diffusion
imaging does is give you a picture of
the direction of water diffusion
okay
so you get a picture of a piece of brain
and it'll show you for example that
right in there all the fibers well the
water is diffusing this way and over
here the water's diffusing that way
okay
and that's just what you see in a
diffusion image
okay
and so that the inference people make is
if you have all those parallel lines
telling you there's lots of diffusion
like this there's probably a big fiber
bundle going like that and there is that
would be the corpus callosum
okay
all right so um this method works great
for finding the big fiber bundles
okay i'm gonna disc diffusion imaging in
a bunch of ways but it is great for
finding
the big fiber bundles because in those
big fiber bundles the axons are very
parallel there's a whole bunch of them
and you can really see it
okay and so people have been using this
for
over a decade to find some of the major
fiber bundles in the brain
so you may have heard of the arcuate
fasciculus that basically connects
language regions in the temporal lobe
up to um broca's area in the frontal
lobe okay it's a big bunch of fibers
that go i guess in me they go like this
boom
right pretty oriented
and you can see those guys with this is
a
distant reconstruction but you can see
those with diffusion imaging
um another one the unsonic goes from the
front of the temporal lobe up to the
frontal lobe you don't need to memorize
these i don't care about that i just
want you to give get the idea of what
you can see yeah question so these are
the struggling good without the person
having to do anything i mean yes yes
these are anatomical images so in
diffusion imaging you don't do anything
you can sleep actually that's ideal
because it's long and boring
actually it's not boring the scanner
shakes like hell in a diffusion imaging
scan
it's pretty wild
we could charge admission for it
and um
i don't know i find it quite
quite wild
anyway
this is the inferior longitudinal
fasciculus it goes down the temporal
lobe so we talk about the ventral visual
pathway face areas place areas all that
stuff
this is the big fiber highway that sits
right on top of that whole
chunk of gray matter that does all the
processing and it's a big pile of fibers
that go straight down the temporal lobe
okay
okay
um
and so um here's a more recent data this
is from anastasia yendiki over at um mgh
charlestown over there and she's
developed this lovely piece of software
that enables you to take diffusion
images and identify based on an atlas
she's put together 18 of the major fiber
tracks in the human brain
okay so nine per hemisphere and this is
just showing you some of the big ones
this is the inferior longitudinal
fasciculus i just showed you and so
forth yeah
um so how does this compare to just like
the most important dissection like could
you see it's a good question it's a good
question i don't exactly know it
wouldn't be easy like a lot of those
things
you know that thing i showed you works
because you take the stuff off the top
and it's just kind of sitting there
but then you would have taken a lot of
other stuff out and you wouldn't be able
to see that other stuff you had to take
out you know what i mean so
here you can surf through and pick out
any of these so it's definitely going to
be better but
which of these you can see with
postmortem dissection i'm not sure some
of them some of the bigger ones but
probably not all of them
okay so here are some of the major
tracks
okay
but you can do a little bit more than
just find them with diffusion imaging
you can also characterize them a little
bit
and this is a whole universe there's
people who spend their lives with all
kinds of fancy measures and i'm just
going to tell you about the most common
one
so recall that the whole deal with
diffusion imaging is it's looking for
orientations of maximum water diffusion
so some parts of the brain have a
systematic set of directions of water
diffusion and other ones don't right
inside a ventricle the water can go any
which way there's nothing determining
which way it goes so this is called
isotropic because you have diffusion
equally going equally in equal amounts
in all directions and anisotropic right
so it goes systematically more in one
direction
one axis than others okay diffusion
can't see the actual direction like left
to right versus right to left it can
just see that this axis is more
prominent than this one or this one or
this one
okay so you're not actually seeing it
move in a systematic direction
okay
so that's the basic signal
so what you can do is in a little patch
of brain you can ask not just
what direction has maximum diffusion
which is what i've been talking about so
far
you can say
how much more does it go in that maximum
direction than any of the others is it
more like this or more like that and you
can imagine a whole spectrum in between
okay so you're just asking how oriented
is it is it like totally oriented or
just partially
and that measure is called fractional
anisotropy or fa
it's prominent enough in the field you
should just learn this phrase you will
if you read any articles especially any
clinical articles this is the first
thing you'll see
in any clinical papers on um that use
diffusion imaging
okay and so fractional and isotropy
there's a bunch of fancy definitions so
we don't care we just want the idea it's
just it's just
to what degree is that little patch of
brain in this little part of a tract
that you've identified more like this or
more like that
okay is it more
is it anisotropic or isotropic
okay
and so this has been used a lot
to try to ask about the nature of fiber
tracks in different groups
young versus old
different clinical groups autism versus
typical schizophrenia you name it
experience you train people up on a task
do you change the fa the fractional
anisotropy of some particular tract
okay so it's just a characteristic of a
tract is how
kind of oriented is it along the way is
it
super clean you know totally oriented or
does it have some
you know
some isotropy mixed in
okay
all right so this is all over the
literature let me give you one kind of
cool example from gabrielli lab that
came out recently
so they identified the um
arcuate fasciculus that i showed you
before going from the basically
wernicke's area curving around up to
broca's area up there okay so that you
can identify it anatomically in each
subject individually okay now you've got
it you've identified which voxels are
part of the arcuate fasciculus
and then what they want to ask what they
wanted to ask is
is the integrity or the characteristics
of the arcuate fasciculus is that
important
for language process for dyslexia right
so they measured the fa along this tract
how oriented is it all the way along
here and then you get some kind of
average
and they measure that in a bunch of kids
with dyslexia and in a bunch of kids
with no reading disability who are
matched in other dimensions of
non-verbal cognitive ability
okay
and what they found is the fractional
and isotropy was higher in the typical
kids than the kids with reading
disability with dyslexia
okay and from that they implicated that
this connection may play some role
in dyslexia
okay it's not totally obvious because
one would think this region is connected
to that region those are those are sort
of languagey regions right it's not
visual regions you think of dyslexia's
problem seeing the letters and which
ones are oriented which way and this
suggests that at least higher level
connectivity between language regions
may be implicated okay yeah so so this
just talks about the architecture and
not the sort of per unit information
that's right there's no information
that's right it's just saying where are
the wires and how organized are the
wires period
yeah so if the water flow
through some technique is sort of i can
mess with it
like how i'm measuring it if there's
some means to sort of miss the
fusion without have any effect
i didn't quite get that say it again so
there's this water diffusion that's
happening that i'm trying to measure but
what if i have some way to intervene and
sort of
change the rate of diffusion
i don't know how you do that i mean it's
a pretty basic physical property
diffusion of water and how it's
constrained by lipids right
but that shouldn't have
uh
like the functional sort of information
flow
uh
i have no idea i mean that's a
biophysical question i don't know about
right but but notice this is this is a
pretty distant proxy you're mostly
looking at water between axons not even
within them
and so it's just a proxy for how well
can we see those fibers and how they're
oriented
okay it's pretty yeah it's pretty
removed from actual
signals going along the wires
um
anyway does everybody get the sense that
you know it's it's one little finding
but it's it it implicates something
about that tract uh in dyslexia
okay so that's interesting um but first
it's just correlational lots of things
are just correlational most of the stuff
in this class is just correlational same
is true here
um but a little more seriously it's not
totally clear what fractional anisotropy
means okay so there's a
real tradition of treating high
fractional anisotropy as if that's good
after all we're in a fiber bundle
shouldn't all the axons be oriented
nicely in there and not all scrambled
surely oriented as good and scrambled is
bad
well maybe but sometimes fibers cross a
fiber bundle so you can have a fiber
bundle like this with other fibers
crossing it and so when that happens
maybe that's good and so people use faa
as a proxy for you know good fiber you
know people say fiber integrity even
but there's a whole question about what
exactly it means and there are people
who spend their lives looking at the
biophysics of fibers and all the
different things that fractional
anisotropy and the other measures might
mean
and it's actually pretty complicated and
unresolved
another challenge with fractional
anisotropy
is it's extremely vulnerable to
artifacts all of diffusion imaging is
extremely vulnerable to artifacts
okay and i'm going to give you an
example of a study we did a few years
ago
so i was for a while trying to work on
autism i've more or less given up
because it's as far as i can tell
impossible
but back while i was still trying
we scanned a whole bunch of kids with
and without autism with diffusion
imaging okay
and at the time there were about 50
published papers almost all of which
said
one of the things you find with autism
is that there's an underdevelopment of
long-range connectivity and an
over-development of short-range
connectivity and so then people would
kind of free associate with all kinds of
speculations about okay this explains
aspects of the autism phenotype they
can't put different ideas together
because their connections across the
brain aren't as good and they're
obsessed with little details because
they have too many local connections and
all kinds of you know
suggestive but very very fuzzy ideas
like that so 50 papers pretty much all
found
underdeveloped lower fractional
anisotropy and long-range connections
long-range tracks in autism okay a very
established finding
so we went in not to raise hell but just
to kind of replicate some of those basic
findings while studying some other
things
and in fact when we did what everyone
else does
that is standard analysis
you collect your diffusion imaging data
and you kind of eyeball it loosely and
if it really looks terribly tainted with
artifact you throw that subject out and
otherwise you keep it
and you analyze your data
and you look at here are the 18 fiber
tracks that i showed you before
and you ask which of those
have higher or lower fractional
anisotropy in kids with autism compared
to typical kids
and the basic finding we replicated the
usual finding and that is overall this
is column a most of those tracks
showed lower fractional anisotropy in
the kids with autism than the typical
kids
okay
many of those differences were
individually significant in individual
trans tracts those are the ones with
asterisks
okay so that's the standard finding in
the literature and we replicated it
however
we noticed
that a lot of the data
like
really seemed suspect and we started
measuring the amount of head motion
between the kids with autism and the
kids without
and guess what kids with autism move in
the scanner more than kids without
and guess what
diffusion imaging and fractional
anisotropy in particular are highly
influenced by head motion
so then we said okay let's get a little
more careful and so we did a more
stringent analysis and we looked at the
kids we had quite a few of them in
each group and we took the subset of
kids who we could match for head motion
okay so now we've got the kids with
autism and the typical kids but we've
now got the subset we have to choose
to match for head motion okay it usually
means the typical kids who move a little
more and the autistic kids who had
slightly less head motion that's what
you need to do to match them
and when we do that the usual pattern
disappears now there's only a single
tract that shows lower fractional
anisotropy and the kids would with
autism than the typical kids
okay the inferior longitudinal
fasciculus
um
so
that's worrying
um but then further we thought okay
since many of those kids we had
especially the typical kids many of them
we had scanned twice
so we thought okay let's really make
this case this is clearly a problem in
the field in fact it's a broader problem
pretty much any comparison across age
groups or clinical groups one group
moves more than the other group
uh-oh
what about the entire literature
hundreds probably thousands of published
papers essentially none of which pay
attention to this this is 2014. people
have cleaned up their accents but up
until 2014 almost none of them paid any
attention to this whopping problem
so we figured we better make this point
salient because there's a lot of money
and time being wasted
publishing garbage
and we want to make the point saliently
so we took the typical kids who he had
scanned we had scanned twice
okay
and sometimes a kid will the same kid
will move more in one session than
another session
so we said okay let's compare the very
same kids on the session where they
moved more than the session where they
moved less and you know what
we replicated the autism phenotype
those were typical kids not autistic
kids
the point is head motion alone
will reduce fractional anisotropy and
will look a whole lot like a clinical
disorder and so every time you see that
a clinical disorder is marked by some
anatomical difference your first thought
should be how carefully do they deal
with head motion and other artifacts
that are going to differ between groups
okay
so i say that not to diss the entire
literature but just to alert you that
these things can really matter
the paper from gabrielli lab that i just
described i looked of course before i
presented in here and they cited us and
they used our methods for matching head
motion good for them so these things are
changing and um i think you know the
field will start cleaning up its act but
it's amazing it took this long
okay
all right so
finding fiber tracks and characterizing
them with fractal fractional and
isotropy are nice but really what we
want to know is what's connected to what
okay
which of these things are connected to
each other which other brain regions are
they connected to
and so to find that out
we need to
not just study white matter itself and
the tracks but we have to get out of the
tracks and into the gray matter
right so we need to start in a patch of
gray matter and figure out where we can
go by following those axons
okay and so the method for doing that is
called tractography
so there are many versions of this i
showed brief you briefly this pictures
before i'm sure you've seen these
um the the simplest idea of what you do
leaving out all the
you know
details is you start in some gray matter
region
some voxel in the gray matter you want
to know what it's connected to
you just follow those little
orientations and you can you see where
you can go
okay and so that's basically how you
make this diagram
okay you're just following those you
start over here you follow the
orientation
right okay
i mean you do that in a computer right
an algorithm does that follows along
okay okay so that's called tractography
and the idea is awesome how great to be
able to see
what's connected to what
and there are many many thousands of
papers that do this
for good reason we need to know what's
connected to what
this is our currently best method for
looking at the structural connectivity
of different gray matter regions to each
other
and so you can ask for example okay
let's put a seed in the fusiform face
area and see where it goes wouldn't that
be cool
right
wouldn't it be cool
unfortunately
it doesn't work
so i have to tell you that i don't know
if i'm a the best person to report to
this but because i'm not you know i've
only been trying to do this for a few
years but i've been collaborating with
the best people in the world over there
at mgh charlestown who are working
closely with us and we can't get this
thing to work worth a damn
and so now i'm actually confused whether
the entire literature is garbage i don't
think it's entirely garbage but i think
it's full of
over-optimistic evaluations of what you
can tell
from tractography um because in in our
hands we started with reality checks put
a seed in the lateral geniculate nucleus
let's make damn sure we can get up to v1
well you can get up to v1
but you can get up to v2 and v3 and v4
as well which which are all wrong right
lgn only goes to v1
worse
you stick a seed next door in the medial
geniculate nucleus which is the part of
the thalamus that goes up to auditory
cortex
you also end up in v1 wrong wrong wrong
wrong
there's not very many anatomical connect
anatomical connections in the human
brain where we actually know the right
answer where we can do these reality
checks but of the ones we know that
we've tried doesn't work
and we're using the best diffusion
imaging scanner in the world it's right
over there
so maybe i'm doing everything wrong but
at the very least i think um there are a
lot of problems with this method
um
so and and many of these have this is
not just me worrying about this so many
people have been worrying about this for
the whole 15 20 year life of diffusion
tractography and some of the challenges
are like famous so to follow those
little orientations you need to you can
see like there'd be lots of places where
okay there's a bunch of different ways
you could go so people use it's
ill-posed right so people use heuristics
to constrain those solutions and those
heuristics are based on assumptions
about how fibers bend in the brain
namely that they don't make really sharp
angles
right that's reasonable most of the time
they don't
but sometimes they do and in particular
when you're going from white matter to
cortex often you make a very sharp turn
and so it's very very difficult to
figure out how to get from a given gray
matter patch
into the underlying white matter exactly
what the connectivity is
so that's one problem
another famous problem with tractography
is called the crossing fiber problem
so imagine a bunch of axons somewhere in
the brain that cross like this
versus imagine a bunch of fibers in the
brain that come up to each other and
then go apart
okay everybody get this the connectivity
is totally different here
no way you're ever going to distinguish
those with diffusion tractography
i mean so people try to get higher and
higher resolution to kind of see down
those individual things but
you know they're not there yeah why why
wouldn't something like that happen
um it's not yeah why would they do that
weird stuff happens in the brain
um so it's not incredibly common but
it's not unheard of
yeah i mean remember
you know the brain wasn't dissolved
designed you know now optimally to solve
all the problems it needs to solve with
the optimal solution
from scratch
it evolved gradually over time and so
there are all kinds of weird things that
are workarounds for pre-existing
decisions that evolution made earlier
and so both brain and body have lots of
bizarre
attributes that aren't how you would
design it from scratch they're just
you know the fix that evolution made at
that point
given what had already been fixed right
and so this weird stuff like that
anyway i mentioned this to say i'm more
negative about diffusion cractography
than probably anyone else because i've
spent a lot of the last few years trying
to do it and it's big bust and i'm
cranky
so it's probably not as bad as i'm
laying out plenty of people do it they
get some kind of answers out of it but
it's some problematic at least
my best guess is that it is okay for
fingerprints right if you're asking okay
here's some patch of brain how much does
it connect to say these 85 other regions
and is that different than the
fingerprint for this region that's
probably okay because a lot of those
individual solutions might be wrong and
there's still enough left over to see a
kind of difference
so i feel like you can connectivity
fingerprints are probably worth doing
but actually just answering the question
of is there a structural connection from
a to b
i don't know i can't get it to work
okay
okay so um i think i did all this before
just
connectivity fingerprints do you
remember this you start with one place
and you
you know you measure how well you can
get from each location to each of these
other ones
and i showed you before that um
the work of zanub sagan and a bunch of
other people
has shown that you can actually in an
adult you can predict
where that
adult's fusiform face area is just from
their diffusion tractography data alone
okay because it has a distinctive
connectivity fingerprint
okay
i don't want to go through all that
again do you guys remember that more or
less than just okay so that just tells
you that there is this
systematic mapping between uh the
connectivity of a region and its
function
and
connectivity fingerprints despite all
these problems i've been carrying on
about have enough signal left in there
to
predict the function of a region
okay and maybe
to say something about homologies across
species
okay
blah blah right okay so where do we get
you can find the major fiber bundles
with the fusion imaging that's
worthwhile you can characterize
fractional anisotropy i don't really
know what it means but it means
something
and you can find very approximate
connectivity fingerprints
good enough to predict function
okay so that's worthwhile
um but actual structural connections of
one particular cortical area uh
not very good at best it's a weak signal
so that's drag
so let's consider the other method
people have used to try to work these
things out
and that's resting functional
correlations
so let me
describe where this story starts this
story starts with a paper in 1995 by
biswal
and this is the figure from his paper so
first he had people move they had he had
people in the scanner doing finger
tapping so they're lying in the scanner
he's skating their brains while they tap
both fingers or not
or tap both fingers or not
and you get these it's hard to see these
two little bits of motor cortex
corresponding to the finger motor region
okay no surprise there we're just
mapping a little bit of motor cortex
but then he does something cool
he puts
he looks at the time course
over that experiment in one of those
motor regions in one hemisphere
and he looks at the time course in the
other hemisphere
when the subject is at rest not doing
anything okay sorry left this out you
scan them doing this and then you scan
them just lying there
going dum dum dee dum or whatever you do
when you don't have a task okay
and he finds that these very far apart
regions
at rest when the subject is not tapping
their fingers
are extremely correlated
so that's very non-obvious
these things are centimeters apart
the subject isn't doing anything in
particular you're not telling them what
to do and they certainly aren't tapping
their fingers
so why are these two bits of finger
motor cortex going up and down in lock
step like that
well nobody knows actually
i mean this was
however 20 some years ago right um
still nobody really knows why those damn
things are going up in lockstep like
that
but it's systematic it's tantalizing
it makes you want to play more and many
people have
okay so i would say we still don't know
exactly why those things are going up
and down together
but the pattern of brain regions that go
up and down together has proven to be a
whole fascinating window into the brain
okay so that's our next topic here
um
so um
okay so here's another depiction of more
exactly what you do
okay
you okay so step one
um you find a seed region it's in here
and left somatosensory motor cortex
okay so that's that region there you get
its time course
okay
sorry at rest
you find that region and then you scan
the person well they're just told to do
nothing in particular
you get the time course averaged over
all those voxels at rest there it is
okay
now you take that time course
and you correlate it with the time
course of every other voxel in the brain
you say show me all the voxels that are
correlated with this region at rest
and you get this
lots of systematic brain regions that
are highly correlated at rest with that
region you started with
everybody get what we just did
okay totally not obvious well you might
say okay fine this is finger motor
cortex this is the other one that's what
i showed you from biswal before
but why this thing why this thing way
down deep in the brain why that thing
down in the cerebellum miles away in the
brain
why are they all kind of in cahoots with
each other
i like using in cahoots when talking
about correlations because nobody knows
what the correlations mean so in cahoots
is like as technical as i think we
should get
court
solutions without a time shift just
exactly uh good question good question
wouldn't we love to know about the time
shift but here's the problem
there should be a time shift because it
takes a while to conduct
down axons from here to here
probably a few milliseconds
but a few milliseconds we are never
going to see with functional mri
so surely there is a time shift but this
method can't exploit it
okay
and yeah i'll just leave it at that okay
but does everybody get what this map is
we've just chosen a seed region a
starting point just for the hell of it
and we've asked what other bits of the
brain are correlated with that region at
rest it's a pretty weird thing to do
and you wouldn't do it if you didn't
find systematically replicable answers
that are repeatable across subjects and
when that happens you kind of go okay i
don't know what this means but it's
pretty systematic let's keep following
the thread okay that's a question
uh what do you like for the addresses
that
i mean that returns
okay so let's do this again you've you
scan people moving their fingers you
find little finger region here
now you scan the same person just in the
scanner you say i'm going to scan you
for five minutes just close your eyes
and don't do anything in particular you
lie there i scan your brain
now i take that region which i found
before
and i take the time course of that
region while you were just lying in the
scanner doing nothing and i get some
randomish looking thing like this
now i take that time course
and i say let's see if there are any
other voxels in your brain that were
correlated when you were lying there
with that time course
and i color them in and there are lots
of them
even regions that are far away
okay it's really not obvious like you
wouldn't have predicted this would
happen yeah
yeah
so okay what if the brain just has like
some
underlying like resting rhythm and like
just always just the brain just have
something like resting with them
wouldn't they just always be quality
yeah okay so there's been a whole suite
of speculations of exactly that kind are
there endogenous rigid
rhythms that are characteristic of
particular brain regions and so those
things go together
maybe but so far that doesn't seem to be
the main answer for a long time people
thought okay is it just blood flow
supply maybe the blood supply to the
brain branches and feeds those regions
and that somehow regulates the gold
response in those regions there have
been many accounts like this and none of
those seem to really capture it it
really seems like probably those neurons
are firing kind of in sync with each
other right um
yeah question nava um
yes before a question direction um if
you have a time delay yeah and i guess
the question was because if you would
have the time delay you could see what's
further right can you instead of a time
delay c
if you measure in one of the regions
that seems to be
seems to be correlated if you measure
from one of those if you could estimate
the distance based on how strong your
correlator is
oh with the thought of that maybe
there's not a time delay but maybe you
lose some of your correlation with
distance
you could but just looking at this these
guys are pretty far apart
so it's certainly not
that there's just things are you know
that the nearby things have a similar
i don't know but i'm i mean um to if you
would say those are five different
reaches that you measure from reaching
one yeah yeah i got you yeah
yeah yeah you could i think that's not
going to work because there are big big
correlations that people find between
very distant regions
i'll show you more yeah i mean you could
try that and i i'm sure people have done
that i can't tell you exactly where
actually actually they do it as part of
their one of the common ways you
normalize your data
is to take this and normalize it for
distance from the seed region
which would be a way to kind of build
that factor in and once you do that you
still get lots of stuff they take the
distance into the image space for that
you can do it different ways there's an
algorithm
that somebody at mgh wrote that is
distance by the most likely uh white
matter path
uh or as the crow flies not that the
crow can fly straight through the brain
but you see what i mean
um
okay i'm gonna
yeah sorry go ahead is it both different
if you measure the correlation when
they're doing the figure tapping action
versus
yeah
okay so this is a really important
question and it's a whole part of this
field that i'm leaving out of this
lecture because i'm sort of suspicious
of it but your but your question is a
good one
um so you're saying would they be
correlated while you're finger tapping
well certainly
if we did the paradigm while they're
tapping both fingers they're going to be
correlated because we built the
correlation into the task we said while
you're doing this do that and so they
will surely be correlated
and so there's a whole enterprise where
people try to factor out those things
and ask even after you account for the
activation of the task are there changes
in these patterns of correlation with
the task you're doing
and that's called ppi for
psychophysiological interactions and
lots and lots of people do it hundreds
thousands of papers it's probably pretty
respectable but it drives me nuts
because i don't feel like there's any
way you could know that you're fully
accounting for the task and so i think
those correlations may be largely
reflecting regions commonly activated by
the task and that's why i didn't put
that in this lecture
but surely task will also produce
correlations right i mean let me just
put another way
if i ask if i flash up a bunch of faces
versus you know it's like faces versus
nothing
and then we look at your correlations
during that period well you'll find
correlations between v1 and the ffa
because when their face is on both v1
and f8 turn on and when there aren't
they both turn off
that's just a task response
right so to be able to look at how
these kind of endogenous correlations
are affected by task we would have to be
certain we could siphon off the entire
task effect so that we could look at
just the residual and i don't think any
of our analyses are good enough to
siphon off an entire task effect and
that's why i just don't go there with
ppi even though everyone else does
if you didn't follow that doesn't matter
i'm just trying to give you an answer
i'm going to take just questions of
clarification now because there's a
couple things i really want to get to
and i'm
running out of time
um
okay
um but but but everybody should
understand this right an activation map
that's made by asking which brain
regions are correlated at rest with a
given region i choose
okay
a seed region i choose okay
okay
important caveat
even though people call this resting
functional connectivity
we will not be using that phrase in this
class because we do not know that it's
connectivity in the structural sense
it's just a correlation
okay and i'll say more about that later
but if you read about resting functional
connectivity it's the same thing it's
just i think people are making a mistake
using that word
okay so
let me get this idea across here
you may have heard of the default mode
network it's there's heaps of papers on
this it's a thing there's a lot of
discussion of it and it's bizarre it has
arisen from two kind of independent
findings okay so let's do these findings
one at a time
the first one is people started noticing
around 15 years ago that across lots of
different kinds of tasks
if you looked at not the
intended direction like say
reading sentences versus staring at a
dot or
you know
doing a demanding working memory task
versus a really you know passive viewing
task anything where there's a you know
in a really engaging task versus an easy
task
you would find a bunch of regions that
were activated in the reverse contrast
regions that are more activated when
you're doing less mental activity
typically regions that are active when
you're just lying there at rest compared
to doing something difficult
and so originally people were like
what's up with that like how can that be
it seemed like paradoxical impossible
um but in fact it's not impossible right
consider suppose i had you do a bunch of
mental arithmetic tasks
and they're pretty demanding and i
compared that to just having you lie
there in the scanner doing nothing it's
like okay do mental arithmetic for 20
seconds
you know rest 20 seconds mental
arithmetic for 20 seconds rest for 20
seconds
now imagine we find parts of your brain
systematic ones that are more engaged at
rest
what might that mean
david that part of the brain could be
anything like daydreaming daydreaming
exactly yeah you can't turn your brain
off you don't turn your brain off at
rest
you daydream
absolutely
what else what are the things some of
the things you do when you daydream
what are the typical contents of
daydreaming i guess it depends who it is
and what you're daydreaming about but
they're very systematic things people do
they recall episodic memories it's like
oh yeah like before i got in here you
really replay things that were happening
and what else do you do you think about
people
why because we're social primates and
that's what we care a lot about you
don't think only about people you might
some of you guys might be trying to
solve a math problem that you couldn't
solve before
but most people in the scanner asked to
do nothing are recalling events which
usually involve people or thinking about
people
okay
so this whole suite of brain regions was
called the default mode network is just
the regions that are more engaged when
nobody tells you what to do
than for a whole bunch of things when
they tell you what to do and so it's
some weird mix of daydreaming and other
stuff
and the interesting thing about it is
they're reasonably systematic so those
are the um
i keep getting confused here hang on let
me get this right
um
did i label this backwards
uh all right they're the green guys
yeah deactivated during the
demanding tasks yeah there's too many
negatives for me here the green guys
here does that look familiar
that patch
what does that look like
kind of not exactly but kind of
sorry
it's sort of near the visual system yeah
it is but it's also like something else
we've been talking about recently
our tpj
it's a little further back but it's
right in the same region okay
and so and here are these medial regions
this is like there's a medial view of
the left hemisphere like take my right
hemisphere out and look at the inside
view that's this calcarine sulcus right
all these medial regions
it looks a whole lot like the social
cognition network that i talked about
last time
that you identify with the contrast of
belief tasks versus the false belief
test versus the false photo tests
so that's weird weird finding number one
that there's a systematic set of regions
that are engaged at rest they're called
the default mode network
because they're sort of what you do by
default when nobody's controlling you
externally so that's finding number one
and there's finding number two but first
jack did you have a question yeah i was
just wondering does deactivated during
demanding tasks necessarily imply that
it is activated during not demanding
tasks we're not distinguishing between
those we're just taking those two
conditions you'd have to have some third
base line to figure out whether those
two were different and that's very
problematic because we're already having
a problem saying what counts as a
baseline right so we'll just compare
those two okay
um so that's weird finding number one
and it's not that weird when you think
about it further because of course
you're doing stuff when you're lying
there right
um but the further finding that really
put the default mode network on the map
was when people started putting seeds in
parts of that default mode network
up here
and
finding that they got the whole rest of
the network at rest
okay
so all of those things are correlated at
rest
it's not just that they're all activated
at rest their time courses are
correlated at rest
so actually what people mean by default
mode network now
is not
i took the reverse contrast and all the
stuff that activated more for rest than
task i called that default mode actually
what they mean is i stuck a seed in
there during my rest scans and i took
all the stuff that was correlated with
that position
because those pick out more or less the
same thing
okay
so that's led to a whole lot of
discussion about what the default mode
network is and what it means and what we
can learn from it
um that's what all this says
um
i'm just trying to figure out how i'm
going to do this because i'm going to
run out of time maybe i won't run out of
time we'll just go for it
okay
so
people started messing around with these
correlations at rest
and they found that you could find other
systematic sets of regions if you stuck
seeds elsewhere and so another
systematic region a set of regions
is all the kind of hot color ones the
yellow and red ones here
and so if you look in there you see
various things interpretable sulcus a
bunch of frontal regions
visual motion area mt or other visual
regions down there
um and they found that that set of
regions was strongly correlated with
each other at rest you stick a seed in
here and you get all that yellow stuff
okay
and then they looked at it and they said
yeah right
we've seen those regions engaged
whenever people do demanding potentially
demanding tasks
they've seen that before in other kind
of task contrast so all those things
that turn on
when you really have to pay a lot of
attention you're doing a really hard
task all those regions do that
um and they're also correlated with each
other at rest
okay
and so there's this convergence of these
two different lines of work
uh task contrasts that just say what
makes a given set of regions turn on or
off
and correlations which things are
correlated at rest
okay
and so they're both converging here with
these two different networks
okay so i need to do a little sidebar on
this other hot color network okay not
the default mode network but this other
one it was originally called task
positive because it turns on more when
you do tasks than rest i mean that's a
really vague statement okay
but it also has lots of other names
and the name that we're going to refer
to here is the multiple demand regions
okay
multiple demand comes out from another
line of work that just kind of converged
with us they're picking up pretty much
the same set of brain regions but
multiple demand means lots of different
kinds of cognitive demand
activate those same regions
okay so i can give you a difficult
spatial working memory task i can give
you a difficult perceptual orientation
judgment task a difficult arithmetic
task in each of those cases i can
compare them to an easy version of the
same task
and i'll get more or less those regions
there
okay which are
that's getting a little vague here but
they're pretty similar to the
task positive ones okay
so
this is both interesting and scandalous
it's scandalous because to me only not
to anyone else because unlike all the
regions we've been talking about so far
that have these very specific functions
they just do face recognition or just
theory of mind right
these ones will do anything almost
anything difficult okay
so whenever you engage in a difficult
task i'm skipping over a whole
literature it's big literature on this
but lots and lots of totally different
kinds of tasks that have nothing in
common other than they're very demanding
you engage those regions
and in some ways that's an even more
fascinating puzzle like what the hell
would those operations be what is in
common between you know spatial working
memory and arithmetic and
you know line orientation judgment and
all the other things that have been
shown to activate these regions when
they're demanding nobody knows i think
it's a big fascinating puzzle someday
we'll have a computational story about
what's actually computed in those
regions but we don't yet
okay
um so the i'll skip more there's a lot
of stuff on the multiple demand regions
and they're interesting but
okay i can't resist one little thing all
right i can't i have no self-control
because i'm not i don't have enough
multiple man activity right now so i'm
gonna have to just tell you these things
because they're cool okay so
um
uh a guy named john duncan has spent the
last 15 years arguing that the multiple
demand regions first are really truly
multiple demand and they are like he's
tested lots and lots of different tasks
and they're very very
domain general
but second he thinks they're implicated
in fluid intelligence
okay fluid intelligence differs from
crystallized intelligence crystallized
intelligence is stuff like
your vocabulary just stuff you've
learned and cached away and facts you've
stored and abilities you've specific
abilities you've stored
fluid intelligence you measure with
stuff like raven's matrices where
nothing you know is going to help you do
it you just have to be smart and see
some abstract pattern or something like
that
and so duncan thinks that these regions
are related to fluid intelligence
and one of his measures of that is if
you find people with brain damage he had
a big set of around 80 people who had
brain damage who had been studying
in all different parts of the brain
and what he found is if you have brain
damage in those regions
your iq goes down as a result of the
damage in proportion to the amount of
cortical volume
destroyed by the damage
if you have damage anywhere else in the
brain your iq is unaffected
you may become paralyzed or aphasic or
prosopagnosic or akinatopsic
right you may have any of these very
specific deficits according to where it
lands but it won't affect your iq
and so the picture here is that in
addition to all these special purpose
processors that this course has been
focusing on we have this thing that's
kind of like the brain cpu or something
like that
um and um and it seems to live in
approximately those regions and it seems
to under you know it seems to be
essential for fluid intelligence
okay
so i'm skipping over lots of literature
just to heighten that this is a
particularly interesting set of regions
here
okay
yeah
do people study novelty
yeah their regions are specialized these
guys these guys will be interested in
novelty
these guys will be interested in novelty
but not only you can do the same boring
but difficult task on and on and they'll
keep going
okay so now the reason i went on that
sidebar
is that you can identify these regions
not just by scanning people while
they're doing difficult tasks
but by sticking a seed in any of those
regions and getting the others
okay that's the task positive network
pretty much
okay
so we're getting this convergence
between
sets of brain regions that we find with
a task contrast and sets of brain
regions we find by finding what's
correlated with what
and the bigger picture of this whole
thing is that i've been focusing on
individual regions of what they do
and the gist of this whole resting
functional correlation literature is
a very relevant level of organization of
the brain is not just an individual
cortical region but a set of cortical
regions that seem to be
in cahoots
and again we don't know what that means
exactly but they're correlated at rest
and they have something to do with each
other okay so we're finding this kind of
higher level organization and the
multiple demand system is part of it
okay
so
how are we going to look at this
um so there's a bunch of these i've
talked only about the default mode
network and
it's another name for the same thing
executive control don't worry about it
could think of that as multiple demand
doesn't matter
but there's a bunch of them that you can
find by sticking seeds in different
places
and so yeah as i just said the big idea
here is that networks are an interesting
level
an interesting kind of unit in thinking
about brain organization
bigger than an individual region it's a
set of regions that have something in
common
okay
but
i've sort of backed into this in this
awkward way of kind of saying okay here
things are correlated with each other
and here's what we know about the same
regions from previous task analyses
most of the literature on resting
functional correlation just looks at
correlations
and doesn't try to put it together with
what we know about those regions and
that just seems deeply weird to me
so um so for years i ignored this whole
thing because i says like i don't know
what these resting correlations are if i
don't know what they are
i'm not going to work on them
and then um edon blank came along and
when he was a first year grad student at
federenco said hey we have all these
resting functional data let's have you
don
for his rotation for a month analyze the
resting functional data i said oh
arresting functional we don't know what
the hell it means let's not bother she's
like get over yourself
let's let him play with it
well thank god she's not as stuck in her
ways as i am because edon spent just a
month playing with some of our data and
what he found blew me away
so um here's what he did he said okay
let's start with
actually identified regions of brain
where we know something about what they
do
like the language system and the
multiple demand system okay
let's identify those regions in each
subject individually
and then let's scan subjects at rest
okay so first
you know first you scan subjects with
sentences versus non-words you find the
language regions then you scan them with
a difficult versus easy spatial working
memory task you find the multiple demand
regions
then you scan them at rest
and you get the average time course
from each of those regions at rest these
are fake data just to give you the gist
make sense are you with me now
now you can ask okay which of these
things are correlated with each other at
rest
and this is now a more interesting thing
to do because we're asking this
principled question of reasons we know
something about rather than random seeds
in some random location right
okay so now
what we do is we examine those
correlations and we just ask for example
how correlated are those time courses of
two different language regions
or those two different parts of the
multiple demand system
and
how how strong are the correlations
between the systems
some little piece of the language system
and some little piece of the multiple
demand system
makes sense
so that's a cool question to ask
and that's what edon did
and here's what he found let me first
orient you
so here are lots and lots of regions of
interest that were identified
functionally a whole bunch of language
regions up here a whole bunch of
multiple demand regions down here the
details don't matter okay
but what i'm going to show you is in
each cell we're going to have a
correlation
between a given so this would be a given
part a cell over here given part of the
multiple demand system and
you know
sorry given part of the multiple demand
system and some other part of the
multiple demand system
or
um over here a cell would be some part
of the language system and some part the
multiple demand system okay
so
when you do that here's what you see
here are the correlations at rest
between all of these pairs of conditions
and if you squint a little you don't
even have to squint much but the black
ones are the ones that are not
significantly correlated at all blue
means a negative correlation and hot
colors mean a positive correlation
and so what you see is
here are all the language regions
these are the right hemisphere language
regions which barely even count they're
not they're just there for the hell of
it
this is really the core language regions
and you can see they're all correlated
with each other
even ones that are really far apart
broca's area and wernicke's area 10 12
centimeters apart strongly correlated at
rest
okay
and if you look at different parts of
the multiple demand system
they're all strongly correlated at rest
even regions that are far apart
something way up in the frontal lobe
something way back in the parietal lobe
strongly correlated at rest
and so
um
and so yeah if you zoom in here
so what this is really
does everybody see that this is really
revealing a lot of structure yeah
question so the diagonal should be like
self-correlation green yeah that's why
it's black
i don't i black
uh
actually what is it oh you know what it
split half a split half
it's actually a better way to do it you
take your data and you have two
different halves of the data and so it
gives you a baseline for for the no that
doesn't make any sense does it never
mind yeah
it's dark red
it is maroon
um
if you look at the spectrum on the
bottom
all right i'm gonna have to solve this
offline because i'm now confused unless
anya can figure it out right now and
bail us out
yeah but as they're pointing out it's
not black it's some other okay
i'm saying it should be high that's what
i was just wondering why oh it's a
correlation of one is that what it is
okay because it's correlated with itself
all right okay thank you
uh anyway does everybody get the pat the
the gist that all of these different
pieces of the multiple demand system
that we identified individually
they're all correlated with each other
at rest
all these different pieces of the
language system are correlated with each
other at rest
and there's no correlation at all
between any part of the language system
and any part of the multiple man system
at rest
all of these can maybe a couple
these cells are all either black for not
significant or inversely correlated
that's the cool colors
so do you see how this gives us
a totally cool way aside from just the
functional localizers we ran to identify
these regions
to show us that these things are
functioning as a system
right it's not just that broca's area is
a cool little thing that does a piece of
language
and some bit of the temporal lobe is a
cool thing that does some piece of
language but those guys are part of a
broader system and these resting
functional correlations are revealing
this broader system and the integrity of
the parts within it as well as the
distinction between those parts and
parts of another system or network does
everybody get that idea
good that's a big idea for this lecture
i think what i'll do
so you can
skip that you can do this you can also
so this is basically the correlation
between all of the cells within the
language system
all of the cells within the multiple
demand system and any pair of cells
between systems here so that's just
averaging over the matrix i showed you
before
okay
and so
this is a cool way to ask about broader
systems in the brain
and i was going to show you some data
published just a month ago that asked
this question not just about the
language and multiple demand systems but
also about the
the theory of mind
network which is basically really
similar to the fault mode network but
the theory of mind network we can
identify that we talked about last time
and you can go think offline actually
i'll take a suggestion what do you think
should the theory of mind network
be correlated with the language system
with the multiple demand system both or
neither
either neither
why
something different okay that's a
totally reasonable answer and that's
largely true but not 100 true what else
might you think it is a different system
and it does function
quite independently but not perfectly
yeah
[Music]
all right that's a lovely a lovely
speculation and an intelligent one and
it's half true i'll just skip to the
data
so in this very recently published paper
um
uh alex poundoff and edom blanket of
federenko looked at the language system
the theory of mind network which is not
just a tbj but these other regions that
i mentioned briefly that you also get in
the contrast of the false belief task
versus a false photo task and the
multiple demand network same deal
identify each of those regions in each
subject individually
then scan the subject at rest and see
what's correlated with what
and
here's the answer you see again
replicate the language system especially
in the left hemisphere
the theory of mind system is all a
system
and the multiple demand system is a
system separate system
but if you look in at the cell where you
have
theory of mind and
language
it's slightly above chance
not theory of mind and multiple demand
the theory of mind and language probably
for just the reason you said the whole
essence of language even though it's a
different thing than thinking about the
contents of someone else's thoughts they
are so enmeshed in each other the reason
we have language is to take our thoughts
and put them in your head and take your
thoughts and put them in our head
and so
it makes sense that those things are a
little bit correlated
language yeah yeah
but neither of them is correlated with
multiple demand
it's 126 so
wait one point whatever am i reading the
wrong yeah oh 12 28 sorry
uh it's like there's a number here
that's how long i've been talking so um
12 28 so if you need to go that's fine
but i'm happy to answer questions so go
ahead
there was a review speaker by like
science and bear and growing talk about
how there was like a behavioral
dimension between their mind and like
when children started to learn
lots of links especially developmentally
yeah
yeah did you have a by an extension of
that hypothesis
okay should be coordinated with the
theory of mind
yes wouldn't you think
not
really ffa is irritating it's not
strongly correlated with the things that
ought to be correlated with
you